wochenlang wurde um eine Lösung gerungen
neben Einsparungen steht auch die
erneute Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse im
Raum nach dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts muss die
Regierung eine Lücke von 17 Milliarden
Euro
schließen Daniel ponszen in Berlin die
Einigung heute für was kommt sie denn
noch rechtzeitig und für was zu spät und
sie kommt noch rechtzeitig vor der Reise
des Bundeskanzlers nach Brüssel zu den
dortigen EU-Gipfeln sie kommt nicht mehr
rechtzeitig um den et auch dieses Jahr
noch Final zu beschließen dafür sind die
Beratungszeiten im Bundestag und
Bundesrat zu lang möglicherweise wird es
dem Haushaltsausschuss noch gelingen
seine Beratung Final zu beschließen das
hängt wiederum davon ab wie umfangreich
die Änderung gegenüber dem
ursprünglichen Entwurf sind inhaltlich
ist dazu noch nicht viel bzw gar nichts
nach außen gedrungen auch nicht zu der
Frage ob die Schuldenbremse noch mal
ausgesetzt werden soll für 2024 das ja
einer der umstrittensten Punkte vorab
der haushaltspolitische Sprecher der FDP
hat heute morgen noch mal betont dass
das ganze ja gerade nach dem Urteil aus
R sehr voraussetzungsreich sei also ob
es so kommen wird oder nicht werden wir
dann um 12 Uhr spätestens erfahren dann
das Statement im Bundeskanzleramt direkt
im Anschluss die Regierungserklärung des
Bundeskanzlers im Bundestag dazu da soll
es ursprünglich eigentlich um die EU
gehen aber vermutlich wird er sich
natürlich auch zu der Einigung zum
Haushalt äußern und am Nachmittag soll
dann der Koalitionsausschuss
zusammenkommen Daniel ponen war das
vielen Dank